pas quatre cages ratée en suède ça fait
un an et demi en fait c'est pour ça
qu'on est si peu présents sur ces 8 un
an et demi qu'on a essayé de mettre ce
piège sur pied on a eu quatre échecs 1 4
échecs deux filles qui nous on l'a
reconnu en fait alors la notoriété a pas
aidés c'est à dire que c'était très
compliqué bien sûr de trouver de koné
c'est parce que nous on a un procès ce
qui est très long pour trouver avec un
test photo les personnes qui ne me
reconnaissent pas donc les filles ont
choisi doivent dire à leurs parents là
c'est mon nouveau copain il ya ma photo
et donc on arrive à savoir comme ça il
ya eu deux filles qui nous ont lâchés à
une semaine du piège et il ya eu une un
repas qui s'est très très mal passé où
le père a voulu sauter à la gorge au
bout d'un quart d'heure et du cou
cet art diffusable en télé et puis en
plus ils sont partis et donc ça et un
autre piège n'ont pas réagi du tout donc
on a mis tous à la poubelle et on a
enfin et ça fait tellement plaisir de
voir ça aboutit parce que c'est
tellement de travail et de temps que on
est super contents d'avoir réussi enfin
à celui ci
9h02 pledge 40 caméras c'est incroyable
9h20 alors en fait ces gens là je
précise cela c'est des grands parents et
la maman au départ on voulait piégé que
les parents aient finalement ce quatuor
zaïde il nous a semblé tellement
merveilleux ils sont tellement soudé
extraordinaire ils sont plein de valeurs
vous allez voir dans le temps ils sont
tous les trois très différents le
cocktail est explosif et c'était de 9
heures 9 heures on les a retenus parce
qu'ils habitent est loin c'était une
chance pour nous et aussi parce que
c'était le meilleur ami de leslie cas
piégé sa famille qui devait venir les
chercher donc il est un peu obligé
d'attendre et le grand père qui est là
qu'on voit a voulu partir mais à
quatorze reprises mais c'est sa famille
qui a dit on peut pas laisser les ce qui
est tout seul il faut qu'on reste là la
grand mère j'ai eu un vrai coup de coeur
pour elle elle était à la fois elles
mais elles avaient de la peine pour moi
même pas le trouvait totalement abruti
elle essaie toujours de voir le bon chez
moi elle et ellen est extraordinaire
ouais et quand l aventure verra la fin
comme c'est ce soir sur s'est vite c'est
vraiment un événement greg à chaque fois
ce qui fait si incroyable merci et les
vrais fiction c'est vraiment stimulant
un film ça dure hier mon collègue
abdiqué lac et dans laquelle les buts et
madame
et
je voulais dire mon chéri vraiment
continue parce que tu es incroyable et
ce soir un match est tellement hâte de
le revoir voilà je verse un juge comme
un fou et voilà que ce soir je pense a
encore cartonné à chaque fois que
grecque fait des trucs j'espère on est
heureux que tu sois avec mockus et
immersive à moi je suis heureux à chaque
fois de revenir et je suis trop content
de vous retrouver tous à chaque fois
hélas pas pour ce soir
tu me connais c'est à chaque fois il est
stressé
et en 2h jugé la chasse et cette fois
c'est la différence de nous tous un an
de travail tu vois
[Rires]
moi de cl ça fait dix ans que de rien
mais à 9 heures qui produit sa qui met
autant de
mamie tsuno sous toute notre énergie
tout le monde attend il ya david qui en
coulisse parce que ça lui aussi il était
là là ça fait quatre ans qu'il n'a pas
dormi on a rendu en retard comme
d'habitude le prime 1 voilà mais on n'a
rien à perdre c'est de le rendre comment
important c'est de le rendre aulas on
dit c'est quand même agréable et on a
travaillé comme des fous et du coup on
est on est tellement content que ces
marchés c'était là c'était le piège de
la dernière chance suisse bravo agatha
la producteur agatha bien sûr que
j'embrasse puisque elle et elle est
incroyable et elles nous aident beaucoup
aussi elle nous soutient moralement ça
va tirer